à jean bellorini allen c'est pas facile
d'être parents
sauf dans notre cas évidemment vous êtes
obligé de faire ça je peux pas vous
laisser partir si sympa discussions le
rôle principal de presidio n'est pas de
tuer les monstres c'est de les
comprendre comment vont vivre et jazz
est-ce qu'ils s'adaptent bien l'idée moi
on se fait arracher à nos vies et
traînés de force dans ce plein les
jumeaux de 17 ans j'ai jamais rien
affronter aussi terrifiant que ça waouh
vous êtes les parents de l'année vous
écoute on va essayer de parler en séance
les séances me font flipper il faut
graver en farine génial
tu as vu un truc pas net je me trouve
qu'est ce qui s'est passé la cellule
locale a été liquidée ça doit être
terrifiant de vivre dans la peur
ce serait quel point on est gêné râble
quoi ça j'ai dessiné sa avant l'ex temps
ce que ça va
et ça vous plaise ou non
des espèces dans ce monde doivent être
tués
mes parents sont occupés à sauver le
monde alors je hais le mois d'octobre